welcome back to uncensored live from New
York City last time I spoke to my next
guest it was just two days after the
horrific mass killings on October the
7th Millions saw that interview many
praised his pragmatism about the crisis
ahead with guards are facing catastrophe
and on the brink of an Israeli Grand
Invasion andit him him back to assess
what happens next and I'm joined from
ralo by the Palestinian national
initiative leader Mustafa bouti Mr bouti
thank you very much indeed for rejoining
me A lot has happened obviously since we
last spoke what is your assessment of
where we are in this war
we are in a very terrible position and
situation because the Israeli attacks on
Gaza
continue uh I mean at this moment
they're not losing Israel is all the
victims are Palestinians what we see
here is after the process of
dehumanization of Palestinians they are
in the act of annihilation of
Palestinian people uh massacres after
massacres after massacres up till now
almost 7,000 people have been killed in
Gaza uh mostly
civilians and uh and in add and out of
of that about
2,700 children have been killed these
are not just numbers uh moments ago uh
one of our colleagues and your colleague
the main journalist the main journalist
in Gaza the correspondent of Al jazer
lost his wife and his daughter and his
son lost his family in an air strike in
an area which was supposed to be a safe
place according to Israeli instructions
they forced people to come from the
north to the South and his family was
bombarded and killed and nobody can say
that they were human shields for Hamas
this big lie that is that keeps
repeating today we were in a
demonstration in in solidarity with Gaza
and one of the other journalist his name
is Muhammad Farah suddenly collapsed
because he got the message from Gaza
that his sister and all her family were
killed just like that he did not have
the chance to meet his sister for 24
years you know why because Israel would
not allow his sister to come from Gaza
to the West Bank and would not allow him
to go from here to Gaza for 24 years he
did not see his sister and now she is
killed with her children with her
husband is unacceptable Palestinians are
human beings and these are not just
numbers no I I completely agree with you
and every every innocent life that's
being lost is a catastrophe in this war
war is a catastrophe let's be completely
straight about this uh I know that
you're not associated with Hamas Hamas
when they launched this appalling terror
attack on October the 7th they would
have known how Israel would respond how
can it be right how can it be good for
the Palestinian people that they
continue to have Hamas ruling them in
Gaza when they've committed a terror
atrocity which they knew before they
enacted it would spark this kind of
response from Israel not to defend what
Israel's doing but they knew this is how
they would respond they knew thousands
of Palestinians would be killed how can
that be what is good for the Palestinian
people
there are two answers to your question
the first answer is that what what what
the General Secretary of the United
Nations said yesterday in the security
Council which is that history did not
start on the 7th of October he said what
happened did not happen in a vacuum he
condemned the attacks on Israelis of
course but he said that this did not
happen in a vacuum it was a result of
the fact that we have been under Israeli
military occupation for 56 6 years that
with a result of the fact that 70% of
the population of Gaza like most
Palestinians have been eved from their
land by Israel back in 1948 in an act of
ethnic cleansing where 520 Palestinian
communities were erased to the ground
and where 52 huge massacres took place
he he reminded the world that there is a
contact and context of what's happening
and he reminded the world of the
suffering of the Palestinian people
there what did you get Mr H by isra no
no no no let me finish I I want to
finish I want to you the rest of the
answer no important
Point Mr now got witch hunting by Israel
he is witch hunted Now by Israel yes but
I understand why I understand why
Israel's been so angered by what he said
because what he was trying to do was
offer some kind of justification to
something to something which is
completely unjustified if you cannot in
any context say that this terror attack
series of Terror attacks October 7th was
other than pure evil terrorism and the
moment you try and equivocate the moment
you try and bring in historical stuff to
try and explain why this may have
happened there is no justification
surely for what
happened I I hope that you will make
your questions a bit shorter because you
have to give me some time to respond
first no I don't think he did anything
wrong and now they're witch hunting him
they say he should resign you know what
this you you as a journalist would agree
with me that any person who is not part
of this situation should be should try
to be balanced right should not take a
one side and not the other and uh but
but but what what the what what the
Israeli foreign minister Cohen said
yesterday that from now
on nobody should be allowed to be
balanced it's either you are with us or
you are our enemy their witch hunting
not only goish you know even the Israeli
woman who was a prisoner in Gaza who was
released they accused her of being a
liar just because this old lady who's 85
years old dared to say that she was
treated properly that they took care of
her that they didn't beat her didn't
torture her and then Israelis themselves
themselves called her aah this is
unacceptable and by all means what is
happening are collective punishment
against Palestinian people acts of
ethnic cleansing and genocide by which
law by which law the world accepts that
Palestinians are deprived of fuel in
Gaza when children are dying in
incubators because they cannot get
electricity but by which law in this
world
120 Palestinians who are in emergency in
irgent Need for kidney dialysis will die
because they cannot get kidney dialysis
including 20 children but I didn't
respond I didn't finish the response to
your question about Hamas my answer to
you is we should have free Democratic
elections and we should have the chance
to elect our leadership freely and
democratically have had we had had we
have elections in 2021 we would not be
in this situation because all the polls
showed that neither Hamas nor fat will
get absolute majority we would have had
a pluralistic democratic system who was
against our elections Israel who was
against our elections the United States
of America the great Democratic
country which is the the president of
which unfortunately is her ing his own
credibility Now by by repeating
netanyahu's lies one time after the
other okay why don't they allow us to
have Democratic free
elections that is the response to
question I think the I think the concept
of free election will be total anatha to
Hamas uh but I appreciate you have that
opinion and I appreciate you coming on
the program again thank you very
much